[Musique]
je m'appelle flore et voici mon mari
sébastien bonjour à toutes et à tous bon
vous avez compris le concept si nous
sommes là aujourd'hui devant vous c'est
pour vous parler de notre vie je vous
rassure tout de suite on va vous parler
d'une brève histoire de notre vie de
notre histoire mais ça commence bien
car il s'agit d'une histoire d'amour et
d'une rencontre un multiples facettes
déjà parce que sébastien et moi on s'est
rencontré en boîte de nuit boule à
facettes et ensuite parce que cette
rencontre et nous amène aujourd'hui à
faire notre révolution donc la
révolution des bobos écolos
alors de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit pour
nous d'être aligné d'aller au bout de
nos convictions et de réconcilier des
mondes qu'on aurait plutôt tendance de
façon générale dans la société encore
aujourd'hui à opposer écologie et chic
joie et travail famille et projets
professionnels
costard et bottes robes et bottes mais
c'est possible c'est possible la preuve
flore et moi nous vivons et travaillons
ensemble c'est possible aussi les offres
créer un cabinet de conviction et
maintenant c'est au tour du management
et du développement durable on est parti
de zéro un sens capitale avec des idées
et surtout leur envie de bien faire on a
grandi avec nos clients surtout grâce à
leur confiance
on s'est installé on a fait deux
merveilleux enfants abel les gens c'est
surtout moi qu'ils aient fait vraiment
mais j'ai quand même un peu contribué
moi j'espère sait jamais ensuite eh ben
on s'est mariés 1 4 janvier c'est bien
c'est pas commun et on a décidé un
moment donné de s'installer et d'avoir
un duplex juste à côté de paris
meriaux du cache pas si vous imaginez
avec trois champs trois terrasses
traversant un rouge stop la tour eiffel
dans un coin le barbu clou dans l'autre
la piscine sur le toit l'été on avait
fait un petit potager quelques arbres
fruitiers cerisiers pommiers poiriers
kiwi on n'avait pas de voiture
par choix bien sûr notre vélo électrique
toute façon on avait les commodités les
commerces à pied forcément on avait de
bons salaires on pouvait mettre chaque
mois de l'argent de côté nos parents
étaient contents je dirais même rassuré
nos amis venez souvent tu m'étonnes il y
en a dans la salle n'est souvent et je
pense que quelque part et nous envier on
était au top
on était au top pour la société mais on
n'était pas aligné
et un jour je regarde sébastien je lui
dit sébastien on se casse je me souviens
il me répond ok on casse le modèle mais
parce que ce que dit pas la berline âge
c'est que nos employés temps était
surchargé qui fallait de gros salaires
pour rembourser des prêts investir pour
défiscaliser
c'est à dire dépenser pour faire plus
d'économies minery si les enfants
avaient regardé les crèches à payer dans
une course en avant toujours plus
effréné je vais vous avouer qu un moment
j'avais un sentiment peut-être certains
entrent ou d'ailleurs l'ont ressenti
aussi c'est de perdre ma vie à chercher
à la gagner
et puis avec notre rooftop notre potager
sur le toit au plus gros de la récolte
on avait quoi accrocher loin 4 carottes
de belles tomates de beaux fruits rouges
de pommes
bref moi j'avais quand même le sentiment
quand il était ridicule à mais attention
nos fruits et légumes c'est super bon
s'extasier devant expliquer la vie la
nature à nos enfants mais c'était plus
possible moi je pouvais plus continuer
comme ça il fallait absolument qu'on
aille au bout de nos convictions
il fallait absolument qu'on augmente le
rendement de carottes obligé alors un
petit peu plus sérieusement le
changement climatique vous le savez tous
c'est une réalité je ne peux pas faire
comme si ça n'existait pas je peux pas
faire comme si c'était pas si grave au
fond et qu'on allait peut-être trouver
des solutions demain c'est pas possible
je peux pas vivre comme ça d'ailleurs le
mois dernier je sais pas si vous avez
entendu ça sur la bbc un célèbre
chercheur physicien que vous connaissez
certainement que s'appelle stephen
hawking il nous a pressés et nous a
donné en espérance de vie à nous
humanité je crois que cet thème de cet
après midi
100 en temps ça fait juste flipper quand
même un tout petit peu c'est dramatique
le mec c'est pas un écervelé fremm 100
ans et des chiffres comme ça vous en
trouver partout des études de ce genre
elles sont pléthores ça concerne la
santé ça concerne l'alimentation ça
concerne les migrations internationales
ça concerne l'économie
ça concerne la biodiversité même ton pot
de crème il est concerné mais ce genre
de discours et on constate maintenant
depuis bonne décennie je dirais c'est
pas fan du tout et c'est complètement
démobilisateur dire qu'on va tous moyens
ça marche pas c'est vrai d'ailleurs
parce que nous on a cette conscience
écologique c'est sûr et en plus de ça
peut-être certains d'entre vous l'ont
aussi on a une forme de flamme comme
j'ai pas une énergie une force
intérieure un kiki germes en nous et
qu'ils aient envie de faire alors si
comme une musique qu'on pourrait
entendre chaque jour que le 10 mai déjà
écoute ce que tu ressens
ok j'écoute ce que chan ok maintenant tu
vas dire ce que tu penses c'est notre
métier nous ont dit ce qu'on pense mais
mais surtout fais ce que tu dis mais
fait il nous manque un déclencheur un
élément qui allait faire toute la
différence
c'est comme pour une plante dont les
racines des gets dans le sol tapissent
le sol jusqu'à ce qu'un élément un
événement comme une goutte vient
transpercer la croûte terrestre et
permettent à la plante de s'épanouir
il nous manquait sa cet élément là puis
un jour dans la rue on a eu cet
événement déclencheur mais non seulement
on l'a vécu mais vous aussi vous l'avez
vécu puisqu'il s'agit d'un événement
dramatique et à chaque fois que ça me le
fait on a répété pourtant mais je trouve
il s'agit des attentats de paris
et c'est là l'une des rares vertu de ces
événements malheureux il y en a bien une
c'est qu'ils nous ont fait en tout cas
pour nous encore plus focaliser sur
l'essentiel et l'essentiel pour nous
c'est notre famille
prendre soin de la nature prendre soin
des autres et c'est donner un sens à
notre vie alors alors c'est parti de
notre décision elle est prise on vend la
parte on trie on vend le superflu et on
se casse
mais les réactions sont bienvenus mais
pourquoi vous faites ça mais pourquoi
vous étiez si bien ouais là nos proches
ouais surtout à toi d'ailleurs mais
flirte adore sortir ta dans les expos
étaient à la fête
tu m'as pas tant nui la main même nos
amis mais il y avait l'appartement
depuis trois ans vous vendez déjà c'est
trop bien
vous allez danger un trou là bas nos
clients aussi
ah oui nos clients qui nous ont dit mais
attendez vous partez du coup si vous
partez on va vous oublier ils oublient
c'est la mort certaine de votre
entreprise
y'a rien là bas tu n'as rien non c'est
non mais c'est vrai mais quelque part il
avait raison alors ils avaient raison
parce qu'on a pris des risques des
risques mesurés notamment financièrement
parce qu'on a mis de l'argent de côté
donc c'est quand même plus confortable
pour nous mais on a pris le risque de
sortir de notre zone de confort on a
pris le risque de dire au revoir à nos
amis c'est pas rien on a pris le risque
de perdre des clients et / de notre
niveau de vie pas facile
on a pris le risque de mettre des bottes
on a pris le risque de passer pour des
utopies qu'à paris a pris le risque de
passer pour des parisiens en preuve
mais surtout on a pris un très gros
risque
vraiment on a pris le risque de se
planter
ça je peux vous dire que c'est pas
facile surtout avec mon éducation et mon
côté perfectionniste pas toujours un
avantage
voilà je les place mais quand je
commence quelque chose bon ça suffit
ensuite car quand je commence quelque
chose je veux que ça soit bien fait et
là je le commence à peine
les gens envisagent déjà des erreurs non
seulement des erreurs mais des échecs
c'est pas évident et pour grandir il
faut se planter retenez cette fois tu
alors notre décision est prise
direction le sud ouest pour se
rapprocher de la famille là où beaucoup
n'y voyez rien nous au contraire on y
voyait tout un retour à la nature un
lien avec la terre le chant des oiseaux
le matap de que le bruit du périph
parisien
on avait des doux parfum de l'herbe
fraîchement coupée
voyez des sous bois fleuri plutôt que le
périph à paris le terrain oui et on
avait aussi ses collines j'ai pas si
vous pouvez imaginer cet horizon ou en
fait vous pouvez respirer
pouvez vous projetez contempler pouvait
rêver alors qu'avant nous faisait rêver
avec 1,7 mètres carrés avec vue sur les
toits de paris
bref on avait trouvé notre en lieu notre
endroit pour créer notre oasis un lieu
centré sur la nature avec en son coeur
un jardin permaculture est un lieu qui
se veut autonome le plus autonome
possible
ouvert sur le monde mais aussi ouvert au
monde avec sa petite maison et son
terrain de pétanque
car bobo un jour bobo tour et puis dans
bobos là vous entendez mais il ya deux
fois bon eh bah ça tombe bien parce que
moi je veux deux fois du groupe
je veux du bo je veux du chic
je veux du confort qui a dit que
l'écologie c'était un retour en arrière
ou que c'était moche personnes et là
c'est parfait mais on veut du simple
aussi est ce que tout ça c'est pas
antinomiques
et puis le beau c'est vachement bien
on s'y sent bien le beau ça nous inspire
sa nos ressources et puis non seulement
ça nous inspire nous et surtout ça
inspire les autres ça donne encore une
fois de plus tu as raison il essaye de
me rattraper un peu mon nom mais la
raison parce que quand on sait que ce
sont les histoires et les émotions non
seulement qui façonnent notre propre
imaginaire mais surtout notre vie de
tous les jours on a besoin de nouvelles
histoires de belles histoires des
histoires de changement des histoires de
vie des histoires dans vie avec le bon
au coeur de l'histoire comme une forme
de catalyseur comme un moteur à nos
envies et le beau le beau enfin je
dirais la nature quand on regarde la
nature
c'est une formidable source
d'inspiration
regardez ma femme elle s'appelle flore
voilà mais je crois qu'on est prêt oui
je crois qu'on est prêt à faire des
erreurs
après est ce que ça ne soit pas parfait
prêt à mettre les bottes après avoir les
mains sales on est prêt aussi à
travailler dehors on est prêts à semer
on est prêt à prendre racine aussi le
prix offert notre pain on est prêt à
faire notre part aussi petite soit elle
mais on est prêt à la faire cette part
on est prêt à faire notre révolution
alors peut-être que vous ici ou ailleurs
vous hésitez vous posez des questions
vous hésitez à franchir le rubicon la
scène le rôle le rhin j'en passe le
champ du voisin mais regardez nous bon
ok on est un peu ridicule et on est bien
mais bien dans nos bottes et ça ça n'a
pas de prix
au fait vous savez ce que c'est que la
révolution la révolution c'est avant
tout faire le tour complet sur soi même
alors fleurs et moi on a eu juste envie
de vous souhaiter à toutes et à tous une
bonne révolution
merci merci
[Applaudissements]